c'est pas le truc le plus dingue on est
sur un smartphone à 200 euros mais le
rapport qualité prix est juste voilà
c'est là aujourd'hui je vous parlais
d'un smartphone je vous ai parlé il ya
pas très longtemps je vous ai parlé il
ya pas très longtemps
il ya peut-être un mois fauchage de
tabourets je crois ça fait bien peu plus
haut le bourhis juste insupportable
désolé je faisais à bientôt je vous ai
parlé du rémi notre set ça c'est la
version internationale version
disponible en anglais et en chinois
je détestais et vous avez dit quand le
smartphone grâce au global sera sorti je
leur parle et ça tombe bien regarder
elle est là ça c'est l'agression global
alors on a donc deux smartphones de
smartphones identique sous tout point à
une petite différence près ils avouent à
la version 3 giga de ram 32 gigas de
stockage 4 gigas de ram 64 go de
stockage
je viens donc aujourd'hui vous en parlez
vous parler de la version française
voire un peu la grosse différence
du point de vue logiciel si vous n'avez
pas encore vu mon test dure et demi note
7 je vous invite à aller voir le lien
qui doit s'afficher par là où par là je
ne sais jamais que cet effet miroir je
suppose que si je regarde donc
probablement être là je vous invite donc
à aller voir le test à me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bon commentaire est ce
que ce smartphone vous l'avez vu vous
l'avez il vous plaît oui non pas comment
et au passage vous invite d'ailleurs à
vous abonner tout de suite comme ça vous
suivrez tous les tests ou les actus et y
avoir plein de choses ça c'est assez
cool alors parlons aujourd'hui de ce
fameux renmin à 100 on va commencer très
rapidement par se rafraîchir la mémoire
sur ce qu'est ce smartphone serait mis
notre set alors vous avez un écran lcd
avec une diagonale de 6,3 pouces ratio
19.5 neuvième résolution eiffage des
plus de 1340 par 1080 pixels
il est lumineux vous avez un corning
gorilla glass 5 à l'avant
il est solide il craint pas il est cool
pour l'importer demande vous avez ici
une toute petite encoche goutte d'eau
qui se situe là en moutons qui un peu
plus grand dans l'est sur un smartphone
qui coûte pas très cher donc on peut pas
trop trop trop lui en vouloir et trop
lui en demander
design qui est cool avec un dos en verre
alors là les jolies parce que là vous
avez un vrai beau dégradé de couleurs
parce que soit le modèle que je vous
avais présenté c'était un peu moins
rigolo c'était tout noir là par contre
une belle proposition c'est très joli
vous avez double module photo à
l'arrière ne vous aura pas échappé
48 mégapixels sony mx 5 186 contrôle
notamment sur le nord view 20 qui ouvre
à f 1.8 vous vers la techno 4 pixels en
un an notamment pour les photos en basse
luminosité enfin si un truc qui est
vraiment intéressant caméra de 5
mégapixels qui est là pour le mode
portrait pour la profondeur vous avez à
l'avant une caméra de cette fille de 13
mégapixels dont pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre
ici le bouton de volume vous avez de la
recharge en usb c'est vous avez une
batterie 4000 milliers en paire eur il
va bien il supporte la quid charge 4 qui
n'est pas inclus avec mais qui va
relativement vite voulu garder une
journée et demie en autonomie voire un
petit peu vous avez haut parleur mono
ici vous avez ici de l'infrarouge une
prise jack
un petit micro pour la réduction de
bruit en termes de performances pures et
dures c'est un snapdragon 660 et non pas
136 comme le rémi note 5 et rémy note 6
il est rapide il est pratique qui va
bien vous avez donc deux configurations
30 giga de ram et 32 go de stockage ou
alors 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage
il tourne sur me why 10 points 2 points
3 sur un android neuf failles
enfin je vous passe un peu le truc c'est
un smartphone qui est cool qui est sympa
qui fait des images qui sont courageux
vous remonterez ce que j'ai fait des
photos avec et qu'il a pour le coup a le
mérite d'être en français c'est la
version globale ça c'est cool et on
trouve moins cher que ce qu'on avait sur
la version importé puisque c'est la
version 3 giga de ram 32 gigas de
stockage me trouvais à 199 euros et sur
la version giga de ram 64 giga de
stockage à 229 euros qui dit version
globale a dit version française c'est
forcément beaucoup plus facile que
d'avoir un smartphone en chinois ou en
anglais je trouve assez intéressant ce
qui est cool et jamais c'est capteur
d'empreintes digitales ça je vous
l'avais déjà présenté il marche bien il
est rapide dès que vous posez votre
doigt un deux trois sade et verrouille
tout de suite en plus vous avez de la
reconnaissance faciale objet tangible
mais en face boyer et déverrouille aussi
très rapidement c'est dufeil son blog
c'est parce qu'être plus sécurisé mais
franchement ça marche bien c'est rapide
toute façon on va pas vous piquer votre
téléphone ne faut pas être paranoïaque
l'affichage aussi est plutôt pas mal
vous avez votre contrastées couleur vous
devenir la règle est légèrement pour
casse un peu l'effet bleuté vous venez
de jeu
un tout petit peu mais pas trop parce
qu'après ça le fait pas ça casse un
petit peu et fait voter c'est pas mal ça
vous connaîtraient si vous êtes habitués
de sion mais pour avoir un second espace
monsigny moyens mis aux arrêts que ça
marche bien c'est cool c'est franchement
hyper intéressant le truc que j'aime
bien aussi c'est en photo c'est vous
pouvez faire pas mal de choses alors
bien évidemment photo portrait sombre en
classique et vous avez aussi un mode
nuit là dessus et ça c'est assez cool vu
qu'on est sur un smartphone globalement
n'est pas très très cher le résultat
d'une nuit est pas complètement fou fou
hein c'est pas un truc de dingue il faut
bien tenir votre smartphone il faut pas
qu'ils bull ce que je vous conseille
pour ça bouge pas c'est prendre un petit
trépied ça vous évitera quelques galères
ça c'est cool pour faire des photos nuit
là c'est pas du tout stabilisé il faut
rester comme ça faut pas bouger pendant
sais pas combien de temps c'est parce
qu'il veut que plus simple mais ce
portrait et tour assez justement garder
là au niveau de mon pouce ça va il n'y a
pas trop le travail aussi du contour et
des cheveux est assez bien fait et alors
là ils galèrent un petit peu entre les
doigts mais forcément je fais exprès un
jus le test on est serein est un dragon
660 on n'est pas sur le truc le plus
performant on n'est pas sur 1 855 donc
on va pas avoir la plus grosse capacité
de calcul d'envoyer il est toujours un
petit peu rapidement il ya des zones où
il ya un peu plus de mal mais dans
l'absolu je trouve quand même tu fais le
job c'est pas trop mal
la partie vidéo quant à elle est pas
atterri parce que ça va toujours
tendance un petit peu trop à pompe et
l'audio va pas être complètement fou à
côté de ça vous êtes sur un smartphone
qui coûte aux alentours de 100 euros
donc bon on n'a pas trop bien vouloir
vidéos courtes pour un partage sur les
réseaux sociaux
ça peut être pas mal mais bon les sens
de ce smartphone c'est pour faire de la
photo parce que je trouve qu'en photo sd
oui quand même plutôt pas mal
les couleurs sont assez naturel le
traitement logiciel est bien
alors attention là j'étais un petit peu
plus long au début qu'on dit oui sur la
photo il a galéré à me faire le point
sur la fleur il a fallu que je me
rapproche pour vraiment line fasse le
point et là le rendu est vraiment bien
pareil là il a fallu que je me rapproche
un peu c'est pas trop mal sans les
petites fleurs à regarder je trouve que
c'est assez juste au niveau des couleurs
et même lorsque j'arrive sur des petites
feuilles comme ça je garde du détail
c'est pas trop mal et regardez là j'ai
même le détail au niveau des d'espèces
de petits poils alors si je suis pas du
tout spécialiste des plantes si vous
l'êtes
donnez moi le terme technique mais j'ai
quand même du détail et je trouve que
dans l'absolu ça va il fait quand même
le job
hélène la caméra de celle ci fonctionne
pas mal bon c'est peut-être pas la photo
du siècle mais ça va bien évidemment
vous avez du hdr vous venir
activer/désactiver métro automatique
comme vous voulez
l'intelligence artificielle pour la
reconnaissance de scène ça c'est cool et
bien évidemment un peu de colorimétrie
si vous le souhaitez pour choisir la
couleur que vous voulez pour les partage
sur les réseaux sociaux
lorsque j'ai fait le test de ma vidéo
j'avais fait un benchmark sur en tout
doux et j'avais un score de 140 4232
version 3 giga de ram 32 gigas de
stockage je me suis dit tiens puisque
j'ai la version 4 64 giga donc
normalement un peu plus fluide même si
franchement je vous avouerai que je vois
pas vraiment la différence pour moi la
grosse différence c'est de passer de 32
gigas de stockage à 64 giga de stockage
les 3 giga de ram 4 gigas de ram
je vois vraiment pas la différence si
vous la voyez d'ailleurs dites le moi
parce que moi je vois là c'est pour moi
c'est vraiment transparent et bien je
m'étais déjà faire un petit benchmark
sur entre tous pour bara le score alors
le score of fates qf sait que c'est le
même 140 4039 ça se tient à quelque
chose près donc on est vraiment sur le
même score entre 1 3 giga de ram et 1 4
gigas de ram
voyez comme quoi il n'ya pas vraiment de
différence pour vous résumer les points
qui sont intéressants et que je trouve
cool moi là dessus alors déjà on a bien
évidemment le grand écran donc ça c'est
assez intéressant sauf que la
colorimétrie est assez juste où il est
assez lumineux c'est pas le smartphone
le plus lumineux c'est pas le truc le
plus dingue on est sur un smartphone à
200 euros
mais le rapport qualité prix est juste
énorme donc l'écran est cool
le fait que vous ayez ici une toute
petite encoche si ça pose absolument
aucun problème pour le visionnage de
vidéos pour jouer à vos jeux ça c'est
cool et autres points qui vachement
intéressant c'est l'audio parce que même
si on n'a qu'un seul ou parleur mono qui
se situe là via du son il ya franchement
du son c'était pas est ce qu'on va voir
de plus rythmé par contre ce qui est
vraiment génial c'est lorsque vous
l'utilisez avec 1,15 parce que là par
rapport à la concurrence
il ya du son il ya un gros volume alors
l'idée une fois de plus je vous redis je
vous le redis je vous le redis mettez
pas trop fort il n'essaie pas de se
rendre sourds par contre ce qui est cool
c'est que vous avez une belle qualité
audio et rien que pour ça ça c'est
intéressant donc l'expérience multimédia
l'expérience gaming l'expérience
visionnage de films avec un casque ou
sans casse d'ailleurs c'est pas mal ont
des doutes sur un smartphone quelle
belle qualité et qui en plus de sa tarif
qui est vraiment très intéressant
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse je vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez les
dernières je survis avait fait fort avec
son red line autres 5 est un smartphone
qui avait cartonné
qui n'était pas complètement fou comme
ça quand on le voyait c'est pas un
flagship c'est pas un smartphone qui
vous en met plein les yeux c'est pas le
truc le plus dingue mais par contre
c'est un smartphone qui était
extrêmement honnête en rapport qualité
prix et l'appareil avec serait 2007 ils
ont récidivé
je le trouve vraiment bien je trouve que
en plus ce design et améliorer le fait
que vous ayez ce dos en verre avec se
dégrader c'est franchement hyper sympa
par sas ma faute je trouve intéressant
on va voir s'il va voir le même succès
populaire que leurs ennemis
note 5 à voir en tout cas si vous voulez
un smartphone à 200 euros à quelque
chose près tout en sachant qu' il a
potentiellement baisser leur éminente 7
est une belle alternative donc
smartphone plutôt équilibré smartphones
par contre que je vous conseille quand
même de protéger parce que il est en
verre et qui dit smartphone en vert même
si vous avez une protection avec corning
gorilla glass
ça peut toujours craindre un petit peu
ce que je vous conseille c'est de le
protéger pour le protéger vous prenez
une protection rhino shield ça c'est
cool vous prenez objets ouverte c'est
pratique c'est rapide
vous sortez ce qui est cool c'est que
vous avez effectivement pouvoir protéger
votre smartphone assez facilement vous
veniez positionner votre protection
juste devant là comme ça et ça au moins
ça va vous le protéger d'ailleurs si ça
vous botte j'ai un code promo de 10%
chez rhinochill qui se trouve en bas
dans la description comme ça vous
pourrez trouver un tarif très
intéressant je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez je cherche le bon smartphone y en
a tellement que je ne sais même plus
quel est le bon rythme à vous ce que
vous en pensez que l'on me trouve et se
réduit note 7 est ce que vous aimez le
design qui est ce que vous aimez cette
petite encoche qu'est ce que vous pensez
du dos et est ce que c'est un fantôme
que vous pourriez acheter oui non vous
marquez tout ça bien évidemment
commentaire vous invite également à les
consulter ma playlist vous présente tous
les smartphones du moment y croyais
qu'en ce moment il y en a beaucoup
elle se situe par là où par là et bien
évidemment je vous donne rendez vous dès
demain pour vous parler d'un autre sujet
toujours très cool tu lui dis donc à
demain bisous ciao